welcome to this video playing pointe du
jour I am wide young I should move let's
subtypes you forget about some basic
things like doing your first move and
this guy is the flag function and
disabled so there's no flag in there at
all okay a Queens gambit hmm I usually
play it with Bishop f4 and yeah let's
let's do that at least this I know a bit
it's a line that I have played numerous
times and in turn of a chess with them
quite good results a 6 mm yeah maybe he
intends to to capture on c4 and play b5
III cannot be cannot be too bad yeah and
only 97 e and you you can play that also
without playing a six-day 6 a-6 mostly
looks like a loss of time but not quite
sure okay so I go I go play h3 it so
that after night h5 i can easily retreat
the bishop this is a slightly inferior
version for black compared to the normal
castles and blood bd7 line because he
has played the move asics um there is a
tactical idea here with b5 i wonder if i
should go for that
in fact the technical ideas after Bishop
basics okay but we won't get them
yeah this is some very comfortable
position for wide the whole structure is
some is not so terrible for black if he
manages to get his bishop exchanged the
c8 bishop but he never managed that wow
I can just take it
what the big point here
I mean I think white was was better in
any case because of the bishop on c8 but
if I've is a very drastic measure it
still on as a weakness on c6 so of
course the bishop now is not in tuned
but still it doesn't feel right to to
sacrifice the pawn
yeah for jihad for something like that
maybe is the IDM okay now i need to
guess in any way keeping the king in the
center's probably not advisable one idea
is queen bee one attacking the pawn I
didn't want to do this before castling
because of Queen a file now no cam
here's some trying to to get some some
some desperate play here on the working
side should I play F for now maybe I
could also play yeah why not this one
just the tech at five is got no way to
protect it
that's probably playing a form giving
away the edge tampon I can just retreat
to h2 though it's not much check not
much going on really
yeah it's two points now yeah but I
thought g4 would be rather save still
Queen g6 Queen g6 or not
Queen g6 ms Bishop deform it's not them
entirely clear
okay just protected Queen g62 age five
this kind of idea was interesting but he
really doesn't have any play anyway i
can just protect your form play Bishop
f5 next
no I forgot about that I've got the
Queen III though threatening queen age 6
with a maid check now checkmate this
makes it easier yeah I'm around here I
mean up to that point it was pretty
straightforward but here I'm not sure
yeah I i forgot about bishop basics but
it's not it's not working anyway it's
two pawns this one is hanging and it's
it's it's a whole rack of a position to
black this is is completely winning is
also dis happening the the whole problem
was that he never got to exchange the
CHP shot normally likes idea in this
position here is to play Bishop a6
exchanging the bishop on however he has
played a six-year early normally you
have this position with black already
castle yeah like let's say like this
only with the bishop still here so I've
lost the template of a white if he goes
Bishop a6 here there's this idea and
within the next remove this is really
strong here this is the point
Black has no move here if he has castled
instead this is in fact still playable
due to worm due to quincy 8 yeah the
point is 97 check so if you would just
imagine this position with a tempo down
let's let's lose a mafia just just to
show it if black has castled already
then there's Queen c8 and he lost the
smooth and hasn't cancelled so b5 is
just just winning so he couldn't play
Bishop asics what I think you should do
is play Bishop d7 and then try to play
along these lines and prepare that this
is better than the game alright thanks
for watching